Oh wilfy civilization
once spread across Italy,
founded ancient cities and may have left
us with words like person and Rome and
even the alphabet. The Romans. No, no,
not them.
I mean an earlier people whose
language was almost lost to us almost,
but not quite.
Let me take you back to Egypt.
In the mid 18 hundreds a European traveler
has been touring the local sites and
now he's shopping for a souvenir,
wandering the streets.
He chances upon the perfect bargain,
a sarcophagus with the mummies
still wrapped up inside.
He hauls it back to Vienna and sets it
up as a creepy showpiece in his home.
After his death,
it's donated to a museum
where something odd is found.
The mummies,
bandages are filled with letters
and not a few letters, either.
A whole book,
a puzzling book.
It wasn't Egyptian at all.
The ink red,
like inscriptions from Italy
made by an ancient civilization.
The Romans called it
through ski or to Ski.
Today we still call their homeland Tuscany
and now here was this mummy wrapped
in the longest to trust. Can
text ever seen? It was precious,
but this linen book had a problem,
a problem.
It's shared with thousands of
other interest in inscriptions.
The language looked nothing like any
other mysterious but not on deciphered.
These letters go from right to left,
but flip them and you'll see that
they are basically our letters.
See the popular story goes that the ABC
spread from the finishings to Greece to
Italy where Rome inherited them.
We're missing a piece though.
It was the trust skins who spread the
alphabet in Italy and it seems the Greek
alphabet they inherited had to Lenny
sounds for them it trust skins were fine
with voiceless patrol car,
but they didn't need the voiced
but go in an inscription.
They even wrote the word
for Greek as Craig Gay.
This is why the Romans, when they borrowed
the alphabet, originally pronounced,
see as both coc and [inaudible]
looking at the Greek alphabet.
It should have only made the sound gum
and in my video on Latin, let her modding.
This is why we met a vexed Roman
who added a tail to that seed.
Create our letter g,
but a trust skin did make use of
sounds that might be harder for you to
distinguish.
Get your ears ready.
Buh Buh [inaudible] versus
aspirated par tar car.
Like pursue mask,
a word that lives on right in the
heart of our English vocabulary.
Ancient reports tell us that they
were also missing the vowel ow or
linguistically we'd say that they
didn't distinguish. Oh from Ou.
If we the claim that Rome took
its very name from a trusting one.
Interesting example is the word Houma.
So this book was missing letters but
it also added letters like this curious
eight looking symbol earlier written
plus the Romans cut out the h and left us
with f.
So this is a f it trusts gins also
had many letters for s sounds,
but only use two of them at a time.
A hint that they distinguished from.
But what do these letters mean?
The answers lie in an ancient dictionary
written by the last known speaker,
emperor Claudius who work was lost.
No dictionaries,
no grammars.
And find after find after.
Find frustratingly never uncovered
in a trust skin. Rosetta stone.
The experts turned to guests. Ology
pull words out of the text and guests.
Is this by chance? Indo European?
No, clearly Semitic. Wait,
it's like bask. No, no.
Hungarian fed up with
this circular approach.
He trusts ecologists took a new path.
Don't pull words out of artifacts,
leave them in then like
a code without a key.
Try out combinations.
Look at each inscription in its context,
combined different meanings in different
contexts until you find meanings that
unlock every text.
It was brute force,
but slowly this at Tory
technique yielded results.
We caught glimpses of a real
language with real grammar.
It had singular and plural
nouns. Clen, [inaudible] ice.
I said there were case endings like
nominative a on kraken pronouns like me,
meaning and verb tenses tool had a
past tense two two care when covered a
language with dynamic and changing
sounds. Vowels. We're trending simpler.
Over time the hero Ajax was once Ivus
but later became ava us or gave us the
word for the gods. The highest
a trust can concern was ice it.
And later a said they used nucleic
consonants where we might expect vowels,
loathing or maybe faint.
Val's like utter lumper.
These smashed a trust can word suggest
the language under wit, a big shift.
Centuries into its written history,
inscription start to drop [inaudible]
after the first syllable via trust.
Skin name for themselves was once
[inaudible] but became rustler.
And in one inscription, a Latin
word gets chopped down to pressure.
It's a major clue that it trusts can
words started with a heavy accent on their
first syllable,
not cross center,
but Ross and comparing translations
and glosses yielded even more results.
Take quasi bilinguals.
These inscribed to trust can artifacts
with the Latin or Greek doppelganger.
My favorite are talking objects,
aristocratic gifts that
speak for themselves, meaning
Moolow, Veronica, Lottie,
svelte corners.
It's very quirky,
but it's plausible when we find out that
objects also talk like this in Latin
and Greek and phonetic,
we were even finding hints of a context
for the language itself, a language.
So unlike its neighbors,
uh,
fascinating stone from the Greek island
of Lemnos features a soldier surrounded
by letters and words that
really resemble a trust skin.
Is this a lost sister language dialect,
perhaps a trust in wasn't so alone?
Did it belong to a larger
family of two rhenium languages?
The language of that linen
book is still mysterious.
We don't know how this text got to Egypt,
but thanks to all this work,
we can tell it's a kind
of ritual calendar.
It's sometimes we can follow
whole threads of text.
Kaylee who through Mish
[inaudible] Tate streak.
It's almost like if you close your eyes,
I could take you right back to
the days of fluent to trust skin.
But ask how to say a simple yes
or no, and we're lost. Again,
stick around at subscribing for language.